GO THIS YEAR WE WILL BE
STANDING BY TO SEE IF ANYONE
DOES.
>> Bret: YES, WE WILL.
SHANNON THANK YOU.
>> UM-HUH.
>> Bret: APPOINTING RON
DESANTIS TO BE THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE FOR
FLORIDA.
HE SENT OUT A NEW TWEET
TODAY CALLING DESANTIS A
BRILLIANT YOUNG LEADER.
OUR LATEST FOX NEWS POLL
INDICATES STATE AGRICULTURE
COMMISSIONER ADAM PUTNAM IS
AHEAD OF DESANTIS.
39% OF VOTERS IN FLORIDA SAY
THEY ARE STILL UNDECIDED.
WE HAVE A DEBATE BETWEEN THE
TOP TWO CANDIDATES LIVE FROM
ORLANDO NEXT THURSDAY NIGHT,
6:30 P.M. EASTERN TIME.
HOSTED BY MARTHA MACCALLUM
AND YOURS TRULY.
THIS EVENING, CORRESPONDENT
PETER DOOCY LOOKS AT HOW
THAT RACE IN FLORIDA IS
SHAPING UP.
[CHEERS]
>> THE EARLY FRONTRUNNER IN
THE FIGHT TO BE FLORIDA'S
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE FOR
GOVERNOR ADAM PUTNAM, THE
AGRICULTURE COMMISSIONER AND
HIS PLATFORM IS FOE
HIS PLATFORM IS FOCUSED ON A
LOT MORE THAN CROPS AND
LIVESTOCK.
>> WHAT WE ARE SEE SOMETHING
FORCES FROM THE LEFT COME IN
TO FLORIDA TO HIJACK OUR
POLITICS.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE THEY CARE
ABOUT OUR SCHOOLS.
ABOUT OUR BUSINESS CLIMATE
AND IT'S NOT BECAUSE THEY
CARE ABOUT HOW MUCH TRAFFIC
THERE IS ON THE FLORIDA
TURNPIKE.
IT'S BECAUSE THEY ARE
CHOOSING FLORIDA AS A PROXY
FIGHT FOR THE WAR ON THE
WHITE HOUSE IN 2020.
>> SO HELP ME GOD.
>> THE LAST THREE GOVERNORS
IN FLORIDA HAVE ALL BEEN
REPUBLICANS.
JEB BUSH, CHARLIE CRIST AND
RICK SCOTT.
THE STATE IS ALSO HOME TO
THE HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF
RESIDENTS 65 AND OVER IN THE
U.S.
>> THEY WANT A PLACE WHERE
THEY CAN RETIRE AND HAVE
GOVERNMENT OFF THEIR BACK.
SO A LOT OF THESE VOTERS
THIS OLDER GENERATION TEND
TO COME OUT WHEN THEY VOTE
IN HIGHER NUMBERS.
>> CONGRESSMAN RON DESANTIS
HAS NEVER WON A STATEWIDE
ELECTION BUT FINDS WAYS FOR
FLORIDA VOTERS TO KEEP TABS
ON HIM ON CAPITOL HILL.
>> I AM EARNING MY PAYCHECK.
I MEAN, I'M UP HERE
FIGHTING.
WE ARE HOLDING, TRYING TO
HOLD THE PETER STRZOKS AND
THE COMEYS ACCOUNTABLE.
>> AND DOING THAT CAUGHT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ATTENTION.
HE TWEETED TODAY CONGRESSMAN
RON DESANTIS A TOP STUDENT
AT YALE AND HARVARD LAW
SCHOOL IS RUNNING FOR
GOVERNOR OF THE GREAT STATE
OF FLORIDA.
RON IS STRONG ON BORDERS.
TOUGH ON CRIME AND BIG ON
CUTTING TAXES.
LOVES OUR MILITARY AND OUR
VETS.
HE WILL BE A GREAT GOVERNOR
AND HAS MY FULL ENDORSEMENT.
>> AS GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA,
YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WE HAVE A HURRICANE
HOPEFULLY NOT, WE NEED AID,
I CALL THE PRESIDENT
DROCKETLY.
HE IS GOING TO TAKE MY CALL.
>> PUTNAM SUPPORTS 2RU6R7,
TOO.
BUT DOUBTS DESANTIS CAN USE
D.C. CONNECTIONS TO WIN.
>> THIS IS A FLORIDA BASED
RACE.
AND WASHINGTON IS NOT GOING
TO GET IT DONE.
AND DIALING IN A
GUBERNATORIAL CAMPAIGN FROM
OUT OF STATE LONG DISTANCE
ISN'T GOING TO GET IT DONE.
>> ULTIMATELY THIS RACE'S
RESULT MAY CAUSE A RIPPLE
EFFECT FELT FAR FROM
TALLAHASSEE.
>> AS FLORIDA GOES SO DOES
THE NATION GOES.
WE ARE A SWING STATE AND
IMPORTANT STATE.
I WOULD LIKE TO THINK WE SET
THE POLICY HERE IF FOR THE
REST OF THE STATE.
>> FLORIDA WINDS UP BEING
THE BACK DROP FOR MAJOR
POLITICAL NEWS THAN ANYWHERE
ELSE BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
THE PRESIDENT'S MAR-A-LAGO
ESTATE IS HIS INVOLVEMENT IN
THIS RACE COULD MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE AS REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY VOTERS THERE GIVE
HIM A SKY HIGH 86% APPROVAL